[Musique]
bienvenue sur arte france pour un
nouveau numéro de la grande interview
notre invité aujourd'hui isabelle
this-saint-jean professeur à
l'université sorbonne-paris nord
secrétaire national du parti socialiste
en charge des études et ex présidente de
l'association sauvons la recherche
bonjour isabelle bonjour le 20 février
dernier avant le confinant vous avez
déclaré il y a un problème majeur de
sous financement de la recherche
française à quoi est-ce que vous
attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est une
longue histoire
c'est ça fait maintenant plusieurs je
dirais décennies presque que la roche le
la france ou financent sa recherche
française
sa recherche et son enseignement
supérieur parce qu'on peut pas dissocier
les deux shows ne serait ce que parce
que la majorité de chasseurs en tous les
cas du public sont dans les universités
nerfs des enseignants et donc il ya un
sous financement à la fois de la
recherche est nettement supérieur qui se
traduit par un éducateur parce que je ne
veux pas assommer no no hunter de
chiffres mais il ya le chiffre le plus
important qu'on donne c'est celui de
l'effort de la recherche c'est à dire en
gros là le pourcentage que un pays n'y
consacre à la recherche dans le pipe et
on constate là que année après la france
n'arrive pas du tout à atteindre
l'objectif qu'elle s'est donnée depuis
longtemps à savoir 3 % de pib qui est
consacrée au financement de la recherche
on est nous allons tour de un peu plus
de 2 e à la 2 2 à peu près de 3 mais
paient tous les trois pour cent qu'il
faudrait atteindre pour pouvoir être à
la hauteur de l'importance de cet enjeu
alors en termes de chiffres c'est 49 8
milliards d'euros à la dépense
intérieure de recherche et développement
en juillet 2018 selon gouv.fr comment
est-ce que la france se situe par
rapport aux autres pays par rapport aux
états unis par rapport à l'allemagne
ou au japon par exemple alors la chance
le problème c'est que l est pas du tout
à la hauteur de ce qu'elle est on perd
depuis l'iss tendances économiques
concernant la recherche
non mais ça dépend des ça dépend des
critères 14 au cinquième set la
puissance mondiale
et en ce qui concerne la recherche ou
bien on est ce que on est à nu tour à ce
regard décline petit à petit alors à la
fois parce qu'il ya des pays en
développement qui prennent leur place et
c'est une bonne chose c'est normal
voilà c'est une grande puissance avec un
très grand nombre d'habitants dont peut
que se réjouir du fait qui le finance la
recherche sur l'homme politique aussi en
france
c'est un problème politique en france
c'est pas un problème politique
c'est dire que s'il y assure c'est
l'enjeu va dire ça comme ça bien sûr
c'est un peu l'homme politique au sens
le plus noble du terme c'est à dire que
dans le projet politique
la recherche la place qu'elles devraient
avoir en revanche c'est un un problème
politique au sens où ça serait pas de
gauche parce que on voit bien que ça a
toujours été vrai et ces derniers n'y
avait pas eu des jeux reflet l'une dès
que qu'on peut faire un hollande même si
il ya eu des choses très positives mais
une des choses bien et bien dans les
choses pourraient bien les effectivement
il n'a pas eu le financement attendu
pour la recherche et d'enseignement
supérieur
mais ça n'est pas arrivé avec des
accrocs et ça n'était pas le cas loin de
son faux avec nicolas sarkozy
c'est pour ça que je ne sais pas chez
politique au sens politicien du terme à
ce que l auront bien
pour l'instant il n'ya pas se finance
mais justement est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
une prise de conscience de la part des
politiques ou ou des citoyens par
rapport à ce problème de sous
financement de la recherche avec 7 avec
cette période pense poste confinement
que nous sommes en train de vivre est ce
qu'il peut y avoir une prise de
conscience collective
alors il faut qu'ils aient une prise de
conscience collective vraiment et que
cette fois ci les grandes déclarations
parce que emmanuel macron dont en
achetant les grandes déclarations et
grandes annonces sur le finançant la
recherche soit réel parce que compte
bien sûr il a un plan un grand plan de
la recherche mais la réalité
ce grand plan finances cherche souhaité
en fait vous prêterez lointain dire que
au moment où il a été annulé
en fait c'était le gouvernement le quai
et un an en termes de financement qui
n'était pas donné
au lieu de faire directement et quand
vous regardez le chiffre était inscrit
dans le budget c'est un chiffre qui
compensait à peine l'appelation donc on
n'y est pas il ya toujours des brouettes
cela maintenant au pain l'épreuve et
c'était absolument indispensable que nos
concitoyens contre elles recherchent
d'autres secteurs ainsi indispensable
pour des tas de raisons parce que la
rechercher sa part des connaissances et
nancy pas sur l'esprit critique il faut
là où il faut rappeler tout ça mais
aussi parce que la recherche est un
élément central dans la prise en compte
et très très grands défis face auxquels
nous sommes aimés en particulier le défi
que ses conséquences
méo et notamment parmi les connaisseurs
les conséquences d'une pandémie
là c'est la première la première grande
qui atteint l'ensemble de la planète
dans le monde moderne mais une
scientifique
jec depuis 90 ans nous annonce une
autonomie
donc il va y en avoir d'autres et donc
il faut absolument que là tu sois en
étant de faire face est très actif de
trouver des descriptions de nous
préparer cette situation à venir
c'est vrai pour les pandémies pour
l'adaptation changement latine de
manière plus générale
mais est ce que savait qu'une question
d'argent et comment utiliser cet argent
est ce que par exemple en ce moment il
est bien utilisé quand on pense
notamment aux polémiques 1
actuellement sur le trop de bureaucratie
et l'argent mal dépensé soit disant dans
l'hôpital public alors il ya eu
effectivement une question d'argent
c'est il faut commencer et j'ai pas
toujours plein
c'est j'ai toujours fait attention comme
zehst non mais et on eu à faire sans
argent et il ya un sous-investissement
donc il faut régler cette problématique
qu'il faut régler ce problème finances
ne serait ce que est ce que la recherche
c'est d'abord des remix ans et que pour
des raisons financières
et bien depuis maintenant presque une
décennie un peu plus nous n'arrivons
plus à recruter les jeunes qui seront
les chercheurs et nice mais les
chercheurs d'aujourd'hui qui seront les
chercheurs de demain
les chercheurs et chercheuses donc une
fois des financements pour pouvoir
embaucher des gens parce que la
rechercher coûte cher et ça compte deux
plus jeunes l'instrumentation s'était
finie que ça coûte très cher vous avez
des instruments celui qui coûte
plusieurs dizaines de millions de même
aller plus haut mais voilà c'est très
cher c'est plus en plus cher mais et
répond à la deuxième partie estiu ça
n'est pas seulement une histoire dont
c'est aussi une histoire de la façon
dont ces ont réalisé la façon dont on
finance les projets et là il ya eu un
espèce de dysfonctionnements qui ne
trouvera sylvain également assez je
dirais idéologique mais il faut financer
la recherche sans arrêt expliqué ne
trouvaient le l'excellence les plus
immédiates et donc ça passe par des
financements appel à projet et ce mode
de financement par appel à projets dont
il est nécessaire d'avoir harting est
devenu se substituer à tout autre type
de financement à part les postes pour
l'essentiel est là il poste de titulaire
bon j'ai manqué mais donc du coup ça a
fait un système de financement vous avez
des gens qui sont en permanence en train
de déposer des dossiers sont deux
dossiers de financement relativement
court terme ou d'évaluer des dossiers et
avec des taux de réussite y compris
récemment la commune le financement sur
projet que ville pour garder les taux de
réussite passée après un quart donc ça
ne fait que trois quarts des objets sur
deux copines elles n'ont pas pu trouver
nancement et c'est une absurdité une
absurdité on est sur des taux de 30 des
finances celle agence nationale de la
recherche c'est l'état c'est les nerfs
c'est effectivement une agence nationale
l'écuyer et à une relative tendance ans
et donc c'est un établissement public
mais qui n'est pas le ministère direct
indépendance par rapport aux ministres
on a vu la crise des masques on a vu la
crise des tests concernant ces
sanitaires liés au courant navires us
emmanuel macron lors de ses différentes
prises
d'antenne lancer différentes allocutions
a souvent parlé de souveraineté
nationale est ce que la france est
souveraine en matière de recherche et
développement
est ce qu'elle peut être leader en la
matière quand on entend par exemple que
sanofi va prioriser les états unis
plutôt que la france
on se dit qu'on est peut-être loin
malgré les démentir alors deux choses
d'abord je trouve quand même réalisé que
la recherche c'est de la coopération
alors que pour les scientifiques
je parle plus de la recherche ils sont
en opération
est-ce que vos homologues niçois et donc
il faut absolument tout faire pour que
la coopération scientifique nationale
puisse perdurer et donc il faut pas être
dans des bus avec 3 on voit bien qu'il
attendait hier face collectivement de
manière internationaux qu'il faut
absolument maintenir ce camp et en
particulier dans l'espace européen
ça c'est la première chose il faut
jamais il faut pas raisonner en termes
d'eau il fouette et l'iedom douche la
recherche sais c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut raisonner bien sûr moteur très fort
dans la chair et d'hyper concurrence
pourrait être le premier
et aussi parce qu'il fait qu'ils pensent
à une conséquence terme de brevets
revalorisation est donc à ce moment-là
de retomber donc deuxième année
troisième élément est ce que l'on est
souvent voulait dire que financer
suffisamment les choses pour que son pin
cette hauteur
deuxième élément la recherche privée de
france est un énorme problème étant
donné sa structure notamment avec d'un
côté et de l'autre côté tout petit pme
tpe et entre et la vallée de la mort
c'était l'absence d'entreprises de
taille intermédiaire étant donné la
structure écoute la france est bien
tout ça fait que la recherche privée est
insuffisante en france et que malgré un
dispositif absolument majeur en occupera
qui le crédit impôt recherche
ça n'a pas suffi pour relancer la
recherche privée française donc faut
absolument trouver des dispositifs pour
que la recherche privée se relance et à
ce moment là effectivement on traitera
la question de la souveraineté mais qui
lorsqu'on parle peu et nick amendé dans
une autre objet ni on est dans une
logique industrielle et non activement
il faut qu'on réfléchisse sur ces
questions il faut qu'on trouve des
critères identiques
on y réfléchir isabelle this-saint-jean
n'en parle juste juste après la pause
pardonnez moi de vous couper on en
reparle juste après sa merci
[Musique]
de retour sur arte france la grande
interview avec comme invité isabelle
this-saint-jean professeur enseignante
chercheuse à l'université sorbonne paris
nord on parle de la recherche
évidemment il avait vous parliez de la
concurrence ou de la coopération par
rapport à la recherche pour essayer
d'être souverains en la matière
justement c'est cette question par
rapport à la course au vaccin mondiale
coopération ou concurrence on voit par
exemple récemment la grande bretagne qui
a mis la main au portefeuille à peu près
150 millions d'euros pour financer un
vaccin
ensemble ça semble plutôt individuelle
la queue collégialement
non mais il ya bien sûr une logique
concurrentielle dans mise en place
industrielle de file de la production
des médicaments
là on est dans une logique est donc en
concurrence et donc il faut différencier
les chaussures la recherche on a
l'explication les retrouver on est un
peu et je suis super content
alors maintenant est la france
hs qu'il fallait à ce que les hautes
baies milk de ses investissements on
voit quand même un sujet c'est à dire
que quand on finit quand même dead
considérable je prend uniquement le
crédit impôt recherche
ces 150 millions voilà donc on donne les
aides massives aux entreprises
et effectivement c'est un homme que
l'accent soit connu ailleurs mais qui
bénéficie avant un nom donc il faut
absolument mais ça c'est logique plus
générale il faut absolument que les
dispositifs des dom où l'entreprise dans
cet ailleurs et par ses pairs comme
ailleurs soit des aides qu'ils soient
maintenant organiser utilisé en cliquant
effectivement des problématiques de
relocalisation morente sur un certain
nombre de secteurs prioriser en faire
deux critères sociaux il faut arrêter
avec les salaires sous des sur des
échecs qu'ils ne deviennent totalement
des déshonneur canton rapport l'histoire
bon bon bon il faut que des fêtes que
les salaires soient tribune en une
échelle échelle raisonnable de nerfs que
mal et rennes qui peut faire ce qu'on
veut extrêmement important ce moment
c'est pas possible et dernière ou
peut-être 1er mai que sur un nombre de
secteurs qui sont aidées par l'état
si on vient de parler de vaccins en
termes de traitement
vous n'êtes pas virologues
infectiologues mais quand un médecin de
ville vous dit qu'il n'a pas le droit de
traiter je pars du corona virus est de
seulement isoler les patients atteints
du duc hoà binh 19 ou de leur prescrire
du doliprane ou de refiler la patate
chaude à l'hôpital qu'est ce que vous
lui répondez à ce médecin de ville mais
je crois pas qu'il ait eu aucune
possibilité de traiter fin mai quand
même falloir l'être je suis pas du tout
dans mon domaine de compétence
mais la possibilité très en colère lui
léchait 8 chez soi confié le et tout ça
pour dire est ce qu'il ya une opposition
entre l'éthique de du traitement contre
l'éthique de la recherche
ce que prônent notamment le professeur
didier raoult tu as non mais là vous
faites autre chose à dire que le fesf
allait différer la nécessité avant
d'appliquer de manière mais steve un
médicament de s'assurer e médicaments à
une vanité et pour s'en assurer et ça a
été au coeur de tous les libyens savent
occuper un peu trop on ces dernières ces
derniers mois eh bien oui pouvoir tester
de l'efficacité d'un médicament il ya
des protocoles il ya des procédures à
respecter parce que sinon on ne voit
rien c'est pas une histoire de on veut
cash kitsch ou un grand complot où il ya
des intérêts sans la mer c'est que ma
larme cherche à décider quand issus
notamment le fait que vous avez un
compte et moi et puis n'est un groupe
traité de manière à voir précisément
parce que sinon il peut y avoir des
effets placé moment c'est de savoir que
vous prenez un et qu'avant voire donc
l'explosion des choses qui ont été
autres c'est depuis décédée action
mullah sion de cinq mois de recherches
le jean qui là dessus de totalement des
intérêts arrêtez avec l'industrie autant
en train de de cette espèce de théories
complot assure un cas comme ça que ça
marche et c'est plein de gens totalement
désintéressé de suez qui admire une
expérience shopping à des poteaux et
quel lien justement entre les
le big pharma et la recherche alors des
liens opex des liens qui nous était
depuis plusieurs décennies renforcée
d'une certaine manière au détriment de
la recherche
et ça a été un problème a beaucoup
dénoncé la recherche des dernières
années en disant attention tout nous
demander de renforcer les coopérations
entre recherche publique et recherche
privée
bien sûr il faut que les mines et les
recherches qui sont troublés dans les
laboratoires lorsque aime ton des
retombées positives pour la société il
faut 4 donc il faut aimer chercheurs a
déposé des supports qui permettent de
farce la transmission mais en même temps
à se tromper faut j'appelle la recherche
fondamentale en toute liberté
r il faut pas lui demander vous cherchez
à vous on pense qu'ils attendent a
besoin un tourneur de recherche les plus
grandes innovations positive en plus
grande dit novès qui est plus grandes
retombées entre souvent de recherche
on y est je n'ai pas du tout à ça on en
a à l'histoire
méfiance donc il faut faire confiance au
dîner marqué et il fallut no 26
partenaires cherchent qu'ils recherchent
mais il ya un moment et c'est travailler
maintenant dans votre question est ce
que tous les chercheurs et ya doute jeu
est une l'ensemble du milieu de la
recherche publique sur le fait que étant
donné ses partenariats et ses recherches
de financement tout le monde serait en
compte tout le monde n'est pas conflit
d'intérêt
signe de la thune ceni de réflexion qui
ont donné à faire en sorte que les
confidents et soient identifiés et que
on ne sonne est un parcours mais les
lobbys pharmaceutiques est ce qu ils
font main basse sur les remèdes certains
disent qu'il faut pas confondre crise
sanitaire crise médiatique et qu'il n'y
a pas deux pressentis antilles fit
pourtant il ya quand même des morts avec
cette pandémie
oui bien sûr bien sûr d or il faut plus
tout confort là je vous rejoins comment
les choses complètement différentes et
c'est un peu la réalité de charmants
petits
je pense que là il ya quelque chose qui
as pas assez les temporalités de
l'architecte son bepa moralité quand il
ya une temporalité très très bon très
bon marché
les premiers puis ensuite il ya
longtemps une petite celle de ses
applications puis ensuite il ya urgence
dans laquelle on est d'accord l'urgence
mais quand on est donc là il m'a fallu
faire face nous n'étions pas seulement
la france je pense que c'est un peu
général
nous n'avions pas entre mes alertes ific
c'est eux suite aux critiques sur le
fait qu'on n'ait pas encore je sens
qu'on fasse autrement pour se faire
entendre
on dit des choses sur la question du
climat
les scientifiques ne sont pas attendus
et là vous les médias fait en sorte en
fait parce que vous avez besoin de
annoncer un jeu du fait de la
scénographie de la polémique
donc c'est le cas dans ce genre de
format réduit
et sinon je vous mettais le pool or il
ya des moments très très grand consensus
de recherche est donc orientée sur le
coup main au bout et toujours trouvé
dans le milieu de son absolument milan
perd vraiment absolument minable
il faut chercher là c'est dommage il
trouvait les prendre structure les
grandes lignes les grands éléments
nation et puis n'est maintenant plus en
crise de la pandémie est là c'est à
votre question ici je crois que c'est
celle là c est ce que il fallait pas
s'attendre à recherches pour traiter un
certain nombre de malades
résultat j'ai d'abord fait les médecins
l'ont fait et après est ce que en faire
un unique traitement sans vérifier que
ce traitement elles n'ont pas été
atteints et le résultat est on est petit
on pense alors qu'alice des études
convoi est en ce moment montrent qu' on
a eu raison à se précipiter dans une
option malheureusement ou heureusement a
pas l'air de faire ses preuves
il faut continuer faut chercher dans
tous les sens et donc il faut la
d'urgence débloquer des financements
vous travaillez sur la coopération
nationale et la coopération européenne
je me désole une coopération et un
financement pour la recherche donc c'est
le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup et isabelle
this-saint-jean d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur enseignante chercheuse à
l'université à paris
nord la sorbonne secrétaire national du
parti socialiste en charge des études
c'est la fin de cette grande interview
on se retrouve très vite sur arte france
madame merci beaucoup
[Musique]